60 minutes had a report on i know
some of you are sick of me talking about
this subject but you're just gonna have
to deal with it
because this matters and this is
important 60 minutes had a report on all
of the ufo encounters that we've been
hearing about
in the lead up to the report that's
going to be given to congress
in the next month or so from
the defense department about about all
of this i thought one interview that was
especially compelling
and the whole thing from 60 minutes is
worth watching but one interview was
especially compelling it was from two
navy pilots part of a team of four
who personally with their own eyes
observed one of these things
up close and uh here they are
talking about it on november 14th
fraver and dietrich each with a weapon
system officer in the back seat
were diverted to investigate they found
an
area of roiling white water the size of
a 737
in an otherwise calm blue sea
so as we're looking at this her
backseater says hey skipper do you
and about that got out i said dude do
you see that thing down there
and we saw this little white tic tac
looking object
and it's just kind of moving above the
white water area as dietrich circled
above
fravor went in for a closer look sort of
spiraling down
the tic tacs don't point north-south it
goes
and just turns abruptly and starts
mirroring me so as i'm coming down
it starts coming up so it's it's
mimicking your moves yeah it was where
we were there
he said it was about the size of his
f-18 with no markings no
wings no exhaust plumes too i'll see how
close i can get
so i go like this and it's climbing
still and when it gets right in front of
me it just disappears
disappears disappears like gone it had
sped off what are you thinking so
your mind tries to make sense of it i'm
going to categorize this as
maybe helicopter or maybe a drone
and when it disappeared i mean it was
just did your backseaters
see this too yeah oh yeah there was four
of us in the airplanes literally
watching this thing for roughly about
five minutes
okay what else do you want what else do
you want
i mean that is okay so you've got four
eyewitnesses
that see not it's not like they saw this
thing speed across the sky
in a blur in two seconds they they're
observing it up close for five minutes
so you've got four eyewitnesses uh
we should note expert eyewitnesses these
are navy pilots
and their job is to observe and and
detect
um you know threats in the sky so
four expert eyewitnesses observing this
phenomenon for
a sustained period of time and
their what they witness their testimony
is confirmed
by radar and by video
and we have some of the video that you
can watch in 60 minutes played some of
that video too so
that's that's about as
persuasive as evidence could possibly be
you know for a long time the complaint
about these ufo sightings
is that uh all of the you know it's like
if this was really happening we would
expect
more evidence than just some farmer in
kansas who
says that he saw this thing and nobody
else saw it and he didn't have a camera
or he did have a camera but it was a
camera from
you know somehow a camera from the civil
war era or something like that
um and that was my complaint about it
but now we're getting
the kind of evidence that you would
expect
if these things were really happening in
our skies
so does that prove that it's uh alien
technology
no but it it does prove
that there's something going on
this is not a figment of anyone's
imagination
this is not these are not weather
balloons okay this is not hallucination
it wasn't like all four of those pilots
were hallucinating the same thing at the
same time
um and these are we know that these are
some kinds of
vehicles that are out there and they're
they they are doing things that seem
impossible
that seem even to break the laws of
physics as we understand them
i think i think that much we can say
with 100 certainty
everything i just said now as far as
where the thing are from
and what they're doing and all of that
well of course we can't speak with
anything close to certainty on that but
it is uh it's something
and and i and i i continue to i i'm not
sold on the alien
technology part of it but
other than that what is it russia china
has this kind of technology my problem
with that theory
that it's some foreign power that has
this sort of technology
is that these kinds of sightings first
of all go back you know
well really they go back many decades
and it just makes you wonder if if some
foreign adversary
has this kind of technology technology
that's
centuries beyond our capabilities
then why aren't they doing more than
just buzzing around in the sky over the
ocean
why haven't they already invaded and
destroyed us or or
you know subjugated us
why aren't we a slave state to china if
china has this kind of technology
so i don't know and you could you could
use that same argument with uh with the
space alien theory and say
well what are they doing why haven't
they invaded by now so who knows
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content